او اتوجه اليك وليد العطار في ديار بكر
وما الذي ترصده لنا مع بدء واستمرار
عمليات الفرس
نعم وسيله نحن هنا في مقر انتخابي به
عشرون صندوقا من اصل ثلاثه الاف وستمائه
وخمسه وثمانين صندوقا دعونا ندخل بهدوء
الى احد هذه الصناديق لنشاهد عمليه الفرزه
عن قرب ونخفض اصواتنا بالطبع حتى لا نزعج
المراقبين
الموجودون هنا هم موظفون مشرفون على عمليه
الانتخاب وممثلون
لحزبي
للحزبين المرشحين المتنافسين
العمليات الفرز بدات بعد دقيقه الاولى من
الساعه الخامسه التي نحن فيها الان
لاحظنا منذ دخلنا الى المقر مع اغلاق
الصناديق مع اغلاق باب الاقتراع في هذا
المقر وليس في كل ديار لاننا مجدون في هذا
المقر ان عدد الاصوات او ان الصناديق
نسبيا ليست في نفسي درجه الامتلاء الذي
كانت عليه في الجوله الاولى دعونا نتوجه
ايضا الى مقر اخر
يقوم يتم فيه او تتم فيه عمليه فرز
الاصوات بنفس الطريقه
يجري المختصون فرز عمليه الاصوات الان كما
تشاهدون ويحضر ايضا مراقبون من طرف
المرشحين ومراقبون من غير طرف من غير
الحزبين المتنافسين الى جانب المختصين كل
معلومه تسجل كل كل الاطراف تشترك في تسجيل
نفس المعلومات ثم اذا انتهت هذه العمليه
تنقل المعلومات اولا الى مقر اللجنه
العليا
للانتخابات في ديار بكر او المقر اللجنه
العليا في
مقر اللجنه العليا للانتخابات وتنقل ايضا
الى مقر او الى حملات المرشحين المتنافسين
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب الذي حصل في
المرحله الاولى على 26
وقرابه النصف في المئه والمرشح المعارضه
كمال كالجدار اوغلو الذي حصل على قرابه
اثنين وسبعين في المئه في المرحله الاولى
هنا في ديار بكر طبعا بل كيف ستتغير هذه
النتائج هل ستحافظ على تباينها الواسع هل
يعني ستؤثر التحالفات التي جرت على
اتجاه المصوتين هل سيؤثر انضمام سنان
اوغان الى اردوغان على اتجاهات المصوتين
وسيؤثر كذلك
على
مسوطين حزب الشعب ام لا هذا ما سنتابعه في
الساعات القادمه وسيلا
[موسيقى]